Thank you.
hello
everyone hello hello my wife in Tokyo are you okay I am very
inside I'm very dead inside right now as I forgot about it
okay so Okay, so to give context as to why I'm here right
now, you're like, oh, wow, Doki, I thought you said you cast
the stream, you got to work on yourself.
I was like, yes, I do.
You might notice something very interesting in the title,
and it says, hashtag add.
So for those who are not well versed with Twitch, they added
this new system where partner streamers, you can...
can accept sponsors that are open to everyone and the amount
you get is dependent on your ccv that's why they crack down
super hard on bots as well so um because like that affects
like how much the payout's gonna be so these offers are like
open to all the partner streamers and it's like a little
dashboard that you click so i was like i was like i looked
at it and i was like well there's marble rivals on there and
i was like oh that's easy that's practically free money I'm
like I fucking play rivals it's just free money and then I
accepted it on December 13th because I was like oh that's
plenty of time there's so much time for me and I would
definitely be doing a guerrilla stream around those times
maybe I'll be doing guerrilla stream next week that's so
easy and then today I was like wait didn't I have that
Marvel rivals thing that I accepted and then I went to my
dashboard and he was like deadline is December 27th 12 a.m
we oh my god wait give me a second okay enable chat let's
get okay here you go sponsored by Marvel Rivals I can't talk
too much I have to guys you guys see the banner thing yeah
that's I was like, oh my god, because it has to go off for
an entire hour.
I like freaked out.
It's like, oh my god, we have to turn it on.
I almost forgot to turn it on.
So the deadline expires like in like one and a half hours.
So that's why I was freaking out.
Because apparently, apparently, It said that, like, if I
don't, if I accept an offer, like, for all the sponsors that
Twitch offers me, if I accept it and I don't do it, they,
like, penalize your account.
So, like, they'll be like, you said you would accept it, but
then you did it.
But it affects your sponsor rate.
So, like, it affects your offers and everything.
So I was just like, oh, no, no, no, I gotta do that.
Yeah, yeah.
So, like, you would get, like, less offers because you're
like, oh, you accepted this...
It was my bad because it is my bad because I thought it was
free money and I was like I have plenty of time And I
proceeded to be like I proceeded to have like been the most
fucking busiest month of my life I had like the May Cafe I
had the The conventions I had all these celebrations all
these events that I'm doing I was working on my 900k stuff
for tomorrow So like it was just so much stuff going on and
I realized I was like oh wait didn't i didn't i accept a
marvel rival sponsor because i thought it was free money
there is no such thing as free but as i have i have learned
from my mistakes guys it's a tale as old as time will she
learn uh and see thank you for the twitch prime thank you
thank you it's the most busiest time of the year but oh yeah
guys i have to read this out okay guys this is where you're
sponsored let me read this out real quick so i at least i
get through everything correctly all right mike thank you
for the five gift that says thank you thank you all right
here you go starting my stream all right this stream is
sponsored by marvel rivals marvel rivals season 5.5 launches
with rogue joining the hero roster and all heroes are free
to play The game keeps leveling up with non-stop updates,
new heroes, new team-ups, and new costumes.
Don't miss out on all the new content dropping on November
14th, which is like already past that, so you guys can
technically like, you know, play it now.
All right, so remember, this stream is sponsored by Marvel
Rivals, guys.
It has hashtag ad on it.
So we all know that it is sponsored by Marvel Rivals.
I started it.
Didn't accept it.
I did the thing.
Did I do it?
I never used this before.
I think I did it.
I did I succeed.
Did I...
Guys, give me a sec.
I gotta check if I did it correctly.
I've never done this.
Because it's like...
The reason why I have to say it very clearly.
Because I assume it is like...
They use like an AI to like make sure you say everything
correctly.
So I don't want them to be like, what the heck does she say?
Like, I don't want the AI to be like, I don't know what
she's saying.
I, so, so I want, I wanted to make sure they understood that
I had, I'll say it again, just in case, I'm going to read it
one more time, just so that they process that I said it
correctly like i'm so paranoid because like i don't i can't
technically i can't actually make mistakes here uh it didn't
say it went through it just says it's live all right i'll
read one more time um the stream is sponsored by marvel
rivals marvel rivals season 5.5 launches with rogue joining
the hero roster and all heroes are free to play the game
keeps leveling up with non-stop new costumes don't miss out
all the new content dropping on november 14th okay i think i
did it guys please clap i think i i think i i did it i give
me a sec let me see if there's anything else all right i've
read it right yeah
click on the thing to visit the brand's website, guys.
Make sure to click on it, chat.
Because I don't know if that also counts, but we'll see
here.
Yeah, I'm a professional.
I really am.
Jakarta, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Wow, cool.
New game.
Jokey is playing.
Why aren't working?
They go to your one sub.
Thank you.
Omni, thank you.
I love my rival so much.
Rogue is my favorite X-Men.
Season 5, I miss so much.
I better watch Jokey Rude.
That's why.
You guys hear that?
You hear that?
Okay, let's do 18 versus 18.
I want to try that again because I, like, I want to actually
experience 18 versus 18 without how, okay, well, actually
we'll do a quick match first to see if my frames are okay.
I need to see if my frames are okay because that was, that
was actual hell going through that.
to swear oh no whatever like they take like five dollars
every time i say so i have to make sure all right okay all
right it's fine the perfect way to test my frames is to play
hella also this is the perfect map for hella um
okay i don't know because like or speech involving hate
because i'm like i'm not singing it derogatorily so i think
All right It's fine.
Okay, I'm really paranoid because like this is like
different This is very different from how like I've done
sponsors because it's all like like you know, no one's
actually like like You know, it's all like done by like
computer By AI when it comes to like how things are done for
for these sponsors So I'm like wondering I'm like oh no All
right.
Oh, yeah the freedoms are see guys look this is how how the
frames are supposed to be, guys.
Wait, did I, like, minute?
Actually, did I...
Limit it?
No limit.
Alright, well...
Oh, why did that reset?
Usually it doesn't reset.
That should not reset, but well...
Alright, see, this is how it's supposed to look like.
Alright, it's not choppy anymore.
It actually works.
Like, I can actually see now.
See?
I can actually see the frames.
This is literally the Oh my god Okay, this is okay I fell
down It's okay, I don't need a seed Just chuck my My little
spears It's fine I have a fly, I'll take high ground soon
Okay, I assume Okay, I guess I don't get healed Oh my god, I
have to reload Oh, she doesn't know I had no ammo She didn't
have...
She didn't know I had no ammo.
That's fine.
That's good.
There we go.
Really?
Are you actually helping?
Are you help?
Okay, now you are.
Okay, he's like, always glad to help.
I do not feel like you are.
Wait, are they... No, they're not.
Oh, shit.
that's a little awkward i don't think they know i'm here
okay i feel like you know when he said always glad to help i
do not feel the help oh one other one red we did it they
processed it guys guys they processed it i did the reading
now i just got to survive for it uh i just gotta make sure i
don't pass out i need to survive for an hour and make sure i
don't pass out i am i i had to buy because like i was gonna
be a full work day like i still have like a lot of stuff to
do for the 900k stuff so i went and bought like i bought the
double shot espresso i was about to drink it too i i should
i should drink it soon like i and then like my can i found
out about the deadline for my for the rival stream i was
like oh shit i swear okay it's fine i thought like i i got a
little worried that like i was not there weren't there were
gonna be hiding in that little rock i'm taking damage get me
yeah unfortunately i can't go to bed yet.
After the stream, I have to go back to work.
It's one.
I might play longer than an hour, though.
I deserve it.
You rest me.
You better rest me.
I am ace.
If you don't rest me, there we go.
They're good at them.
Good!
That's right.
Me.
Okay, well, well, alright.
Yes, I go back in here.
If that's strange, oh, it's me.
Right after.
I will be so sad.
Oh, I guess I walk here now.
Oh.
There we go.
Really?
Because I feel like that's a lot.
Oh, I got her.
I got her down with me.
I took her down with me.
Oh, it wasn't even her.
It was some random guy.
It's fine.
I'm still is.
Kid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kid, don't you dare age me right now.
I've been working.
This is, I've been doing longer than a nine.
I'm doing a nine to five and overtime right now.
I actually treated myself with like outside, like with a
restaurant.
Because I was like, I did so much work.
I'm going to go.
I was like, I did so much work.
I'm like, what the?
I turned around because I was like oh I got healed let me
let me turn around and then the entire army is here res me
res me there we go there we go I deserve that res I
literally like clutched it for the team I will I will go in
there there you go is that the ultron That's right!
That is not right.
That is...
That is no longer right.
That is no...
Alright.
Okay, never mind.
No, don't worry.
I'm not playing rank yet.
I'm doing this and then 18 versus 18.
Because I want to know what that's like with, like, my
frames back.
Guys, we don't have to go that way.
You know there's another...
There's like three entrances, right?
Guys, you guys know that, right?
There is a front area right here.
Like...
Okay, I guess I...
What the...
That guy was just hiding in the...
Alright, you think my team...
They're running!
This is quick play!
Ma'am!
Quick play!
Why are they running triple support?
Oh my god.
I have an atom and then they have triple support.
Bro, quick- I play quick play to avoid triple support.
What the?
What is?
I can't even kill them because they just- it's like that
fucking- that daredevil clip.
Was it from Necros?
He's trying to fucking kill one guy.
He's trying to kill one guy and then, like, literally,
literally two.
Yeah, kill one.
Okay, I need to show you guys this clip.
This is actually really funny.
It's so funny.
There's this guy.
This Necro's trying to kill one Jeff and he's just literally
AFKing.
And there's two supports where he was just trying to, him
non-stop it's like crazy it's really he's like unskillable
this is what it's like this is actually like the life like
playing against triple support i know how dps feels now like
as the support player i was like it's fine like because i
didn't have to play against now i know now i know now i know
why why they're crying
no one gets past this point it's actually great let me see
if i can find the clip it's so funny he's like the gem was
literally just it was a actual afk like he's not doing
anything watch i do this and then the phoenix is gonna oh
like he's actually just saving it for me that's crazy that's
so cringe all right no it's like i can't do anything at
least not like i have to use it.
Did you know?
This guy's literally just saving it for me.
Gringes out.
Bro, it's quick play.
It's not this deep.
Why are we strategizing in quick play, guys?
It's not that deep, bro.
Bro, it's not that deep.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
I'm playing DPS because I wanted to test frames and now they
go through Oh my god, wait, are they oh my god, they went to
okay, it's 2-2-2 now Oh, at least this triple support's
gone, but they went mag bro strange mag wait Okay, we do
have a I forgot like rogue is barely cut.
It's like an off tank They have a main tank and an off tank.
They have everything this team wants to win so Bro Let's see
what's the win so badly in quick plays.
Oh, you see that?
He's trying to...
Oh, right here.
There we go.
I was trying to get into the shield, but it didn't let me.
That's my bad.
That was me fucking around.
I did take that.
Shit was real.
I was sort of fucking around there.
I didn't take that thing seriously.
I was just like, oh, that's just a squirrel.
I can just walk back to it, right?
I unfortunately could not.
Surprisingly, I could not just walk back to it.
Hello.
It's crazy.
Crazy, I couldn't just walk back to it.
That's crazy that...
Watch this, guys.
You want to see something?
Something happened again?
Look.
Just like clockwork.
Oh, wow.
Wow, what happened?
I'll take that.
Guys, I think you might need help the Adam, though.
I think you...
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Okay.
How the fuck yeah, I was gonna say, I was still getting
healed.
The great thing about it is that he did...
Alright, there we go.
Yeah, fuck that Phoenix.
Get it out of here.
Yeah, fuck off.
You guys want to play an actual cop.
Like, I was just like, these guys actually wanted to win so
bad.
It's...
These guys really wanted to win.
Are you the real?
No.
And then I leave.
Now he'll never know if I was real or not.
Alright, let's create a lobby.
I've been wanting to try this out with actual real frames.
Not dokey bird.
There we go.
Where is room settings?
Wait, no.
Oh, wait, here we go.
Research row.
No, that's not it.
Arcade.
18 versus 18.
There we go.
How do you guys know?
Wait, how do you guys know this was the room?
All right.
the room oh yeah the necro the room is not dokey bird that
is the room all right let me find you guys the the clip is
actually really fucking funny it's i saw that i was like
okay wait uh
it's just like okay where's the i think it's from necro's
twitter right
who tweeted it who tweeted it
I'm trying to remember who tweeted it guys I need to find oh
wait I remember I remember where it is uh I don't have to
find it
let's see oh here it is it's so funny look look at this
video I can't show it I mean I technically I can download
the video and show it to you guys to want it to work it's so
fucking funny though
he literally like yeah the jeff just stood yeah i know the
jeff is literally just standing there he can't fucking do
anything he literally can't kill him because he's just too
strong guys i don't know if i have 18 people
he's just standing there menacingly Watch the video.
Here it is.
Zuna, thank you much.
Which prize?
Thank you.
Yeah, because the two other supports are fucking... He's
like, the two other supports are literally keeping him
alive.
It is very impromptu.
I was like, alright guys, I'm gonna do...
I actually was panicking.
I was like, oh, fuck!
Because, like, I remember I was...
Like, when I first saw the new sponsors tab, they were like,
oh, if you don't do your sponsors, you're gonna penalized
and your sponsor died and i was like oh what if there's was
really good sponsor that i really want to do in the future
but then i couldn't do it because you're that one time i
forgot about my my marvel rival sponsor jeff is the only
dick you need the fact that he didn't even do like that's
how confident the guy was he was like no i've not got this
like nah i wouldn't
also eric i thank you for that uh tip thank you for the
donation thank you thank you just want to say you seem like
a really cool dude uh merry merry christmas and happy new
year to y'all thank you thank you for the donation thank you
thank you i really did appreciate it thank you so much guys
you know marvel rivals is free right now guys it's free
right now so you could technically you could technically
download the game and but it is i will say it is 100 plus
gigabytes uh just a little warning there might be a chance
where after you down try to download the game um we might be
done uh but i believe in guys but maybe maybe there's hope
you know maybe your pc will perform a miracle
before maybe it'll be it'll finish downloading under 15
minutes i
will but then if you doubt or you can buy a console right
now and download it on console because there's apparently
less than 100 gigabytes on console you can download it on
steam or on your playstation store or or microsoft store is
that what it's called xbox xbox store i don't know i'm sorry
i don't know what it's
wait a minute what are these ranks oh yeah it's pretty even
up all right we have one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten we have 12 more slots you know what maybe okay i'm
going to put the room up for our game pass yeah the game
pass i'm going to find if i put everyone on my side and it's
just i just put everyone but everyone else on my side and we
fight the remaining people here oh paul high ranks and yeah
that's that's something i would do actually but like maybe
i'll do i'll do two games one game where it's now we're
coincidentally when we do randomize somehow they are all on
my team wouldn't that be so silly guys but it's not
dokeybird you literally you can just search up dokeybird and
and then you'll find me
that's how you'll find me let's see we have we're almost
done we're almost full one two three four oh my gosh guys
please you're moving
50, 60, 70, 18, 90.
We have seven more slots, guys.
Seven more slots.
It says not Doki Bird.
Sorry, I have to look up.
Not Doki Bird, guys.
Not Doki Bird.
Yeah, I realized I could just count this.
Five more, guys.
Five more slots.
Oh, oh, wait.
Two more.
Come on.
Come on, come out.
Oh, I could start right now.
And then you guys would be down to play.
All right.
Oh, we're here.
We're in.
All right, let's start right away.
Start.
Game start.
All right.
Gord, thank you for the 500 bitties.
Okay, this time.
I wonder if...
Yeah, I think Gambit would be good.
What did we just...
Guys, what did we all go support?
We can never die.
What did we all go Gambit?
All Gambit.
guys if we all play gambit like just think about it if we're
all gambit is the most powerful it'll be like and they can
never heal think about it guys don't never be able to heal
because we'll just keep anti them just okay we're okay we
lost two of our gambit wait that's not okay guys for the
strat to work we have to be able guys i don't think the all
gambit strat is working guys okay maybe not guys i think we
gotta swap up to all get like swap off all gambits like i
think i don't know how but we already messed up the strat i
i don't know how wait wait i have an idea guys half gambit
half moon knight imagine just think about that they're all
bunched up think about they're all bunched up so like
because they're all bunched up um you can farm so much like
it's literally like easy cheat code
okay oh my god guys that's right that's right guys if we
keep doing gambit all like a gambit all that never ends yes
Okay, our strat is not working.
Wait, I have an idea.
Okay, wait, I have...
Oh, oh, and then I'll show you guys my master plan.
Watch this.
Okay, guys, the Hall Gambit might not be working anymore.
I think that was a mistake.
I might not be very good at theory crafting.
I might not be a great theory crafter.
Oh my god, the double Gambit.
guys why am i like 1v5 right now okay this is it guys watch
this watch this guys
watch this oh my god the whole thing okay right here oh my
god i'm doing so much damage though bro
wait where are they
Look at that!
Look at all that!
Oh my god, oh my god, okay, my fucking game lagged there.
Okay, this like random bullshit thing is not working out for
me.
Guys, why are you not grouping up?
Why?
The one time I need you to group up.
There you go.
There we go, there we go, there we go See random bullshit,
random bullshit Guys, group up, guys Enemy, enemy, group up
Hello, sir, sir, sir There we go, there we go Okay, they
figure out my strat Now they're not grouping up anymore,
guys Now I don't know, that was literally My only thing, my
only strat Like, I don't know, they already like Fucked up
my plan Wait, how do I...
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, wait, what hit me?
Where the fuck?
There was a... I can't tell what hit me.
Okay, guys, I figured out the new strat in the beginning.
This is the strat right here.
It's okay, look at that, look at that.
Free farm, free farm.
I already got my own, I got my own, I got my own.
Oh my god.
Guys, is this sort of noticeable that I don't play Moon
Knight?
Okay, I think like my lack of Moon Knight.
Okay, I still got him.
No!
Never would have guessed.
Wait!
Wait, guys, okay.
Okay.
I know what to do now.
I have the perfect theory.
The perfect theory now.
Guys, guys, guys.
Okay, my first meta-crafting did not go so well.
But don't worry, guys.
I can learn from this.
Look, I can learn from this.
I can build on this.
All right.
Random swap.
Here, we'll try again.
I randomized it.
this watch this
okay what we do guys we go in with moon night first because
everyone will be grouped up together guys think about that
think think they're all gonna be grouped up together rushing
in and then okay they might be stream sniping right now but
they don't know that okay maybe i'm fucking with them you
know maybe i'm not on moon night right now you know now
they're too big Okay, watch this.
And then, oh, look at that.
Look at that.
Look at, look at them all grouped up.
And, and, look at that.
All grouped up.
Look at that.
Oh, my God.
See, I told you.
I told you.
I told you that they'll be all grouped up.
I just didn't hit my shot, though.
The first part, the first part, they're always grouped up.
See?
Okay, I told you!
I told you!
My theory!
I theory crafted.
Now!
Now I can swap.
After I conducted my perfect theory craft.
There we go.
What the?
Oh, fuck.
Don't look at that one, though.
Don't look at...
Don't look at that, though.
Get hot forever.
I told you, you can't hot forever.
I mean, I don't know where she went, but, like, I got her
teammate.
Come on.
That's right.
What the fuck?
How are you so alive?
I managed to heal.
Might be a good eye.
the other here no wait i'm mvp look at that look at that i
told you i could theory craft you guys did believe me
okay i'm leaving she didn't get it you didn't get oh he
didn't get the heal
what oh my god that that jeff ate so many people No!
The fucking ass!
That's cheating!
There you go.
I saved your life.
You're welcome.
Oh, that Moon Knight don't know!
That Moon Knight was so unaware.
I'm just gonna stay up here.
I'm gonna take his place.
Yeah, I don't want to be down there.
I don't want to be down there.
That looks so dumb.
dangerous what the fuck it's the guy we killed earlier he
came back it's okay
wait wait a minute there's so many people in that corner oh
wait that's not good that's not good i went to one dangerous
place to another i feel like i should i should actually heal
more to get ult charged but like i'll worry about that later
Guys, get out of here.
Yeah, that's right.
He did.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's not fair.
Wait, what the fuck?
He did the tired team chase me.
That's illegal.
That's looking right.
Get out of here.
I healed.
I did my job.
I did my one heal.
Oh.
Oh, hello?
Okay, Jeff, what are you doing here?
What is two Jeffs doing here?
What?
Bro, I'm getting sabotaged.
Oh, my God.
I'm just getting cast by moons now.
It's just all moons.
Uh-oh, all moons.
Okay, I got her, though.
It's fine.
I'm fine with that.
Now I just need...
Yeah!
I told you!
needed one game to cook it up i told you guys nice my strat
worked my theory craft worked we go in with moon night
because they all are always grouped up together and then the
second one and the second and then the second half we i swap
gambit easy easiest game of my life see the moon night one
because they're all grouped together Too many people.
Okay, now, GG's everyone.
Now I go back to rank.
Now I actually play a rank game.
I have not played rank in a long time, so I cannot wait to
get...
Well, that's...
That might be a semi-live, because I did play rank
off-stream.
I haven't played rank since Monday.
Was it Monday?
Yeah, Monday.
Monday.
So...
So we'll see.
Oh, and an insta-kill.
That's the best part.
All right, here we go.
I can't wait to get yelled at today.
I worked.
I did a 9-5 in overtime.
And then I can't wait to get yelled at.
Technically, I can't wait to get yelled at on my overtime.
You get used to it.
It's like, you know, it's like working in retail.
Yeah.
How am I going to vanish from this match?
Oh yeah, I need to remember to swap the chat to this one.
Oh wait, not this one.
Where's the other one?
Where's the one where you can see my teammates die and
disappoint me as always?
I'm too lazy.
All right, we won't be able to look at my teammates.
See who's who did that that I'm sorry my like I said my
brain is really fried right now I'm like my brain is
incredibly fried.
I have been on the clock the entire day
My brain is much perfect for rivals though
Thank you so much for the raid period.
I hope you had a great stream All right, only bad low-key
that means they have a gamut player, but they don't want to
do double double gambits
all right here we go sorry i disassociated i disassociated
for like 10 seconds all right i'm locked in it's going well
right now it's going well oh wait man thank you for the
twitch prime think i had i came back to reality my soul left
my body for 10 seconds but i'm ready i'm not fucking ready
Guys, I don't think she's okay.
No, no, no, I'm fine.
I'm so funky ready, guys.
We're snatched.
I made it back in time to reality.
We'll be fine.
We forced refresh.
I did a forced reboot on the brain.
Alright.
Oh, I just didn't do this earlier.
There you go.
I got free all charge from that.
Oh, they do have a Spider-Man.
I mean, I'm on Gambit, but I also need my suit to protect.
I'll save my shit.
Yeah, I don't want to be over there.
I'm going to save it for years.
We're fine.
See, we're so healthy.
And I've got an anti in there, too.
That's my damage for the day.
I want to do more damage, but like, I'm too scared for my
team right now.
Okay, I can't.
What the fuck did I do damage on?
Nice.
Is everybody fine?
We're all fine, right?
Are you fucking...
Okay, there you go.
It's okay.
I wasted my card, but it's okay.
She just timed her jump at the perfect moment.
Alright, I'm just gonna get out of here.
See, though, that we're so healthy.
Oh.
back out a little bit oh you're on spider-man nice i don't i
just gotta like make sure i don't fucking get a headshot
that's easy right there's no way that's gonna happen to me
right oh nice i have it i'm i could use it here okay let's
do let's use it yeah are they okay i'm going going back I'm
going back.
Yeah, I had a feeling It's alright Not me though.
Wait, did he did he got rid of the rock?
Wait, he didn't even use it.
Oh, that's embarrassing That's so embarrassing, bro.
You didn't even get a chance to throw your rock
Yeah, I'm not standing in there.
That's the way There you go.
Oh shit these guys want to win That's when you know All
right, nice push Are you okay?
Will you be fine?
Will I be fine?
Oh my god.
Oh my god Okay, I was apparently not fine I did not realize
like 20 things what happened in five seconds I was not aware
all right we could still we could still engage I am not
doing enough damage but like I am also very paranoid for my
team god damn it i'm working i'm working i'm working okay
i'm going back into here
oh my god okay i could have died there i could have died
there but i'm okay at one time i wanted to go all in there
she is where the fuck is she
she's fine all right yeah it's like don't worry guys i'll
live and then like 20 all just showed up no i'm heal botting
way too much on gambit gambit and then we can go mag me i'm
heal botting way too much but i'm so paranoid right what the
fuck what how long's it waiting he's been waiting 20 years i
waited 20 years for that That's crazy.
That man waited so long for the perk.
Where did he go?
Oh my god, I lost him.
I actually, I could have killed him.
If I didn't lose him, I actually could have killed him.
I don't, yeah, I don't think that's happening, you guys.
I didn't have a dash.
I would have killed him if I had a dash.
He was so lucky.
That guy, that Namor actually, that...
wait i got time so hard you waited 20 years back there for
the perfect moment what this fucking starlight again bro at
least a mag went to protect me instead i thought i
appreciate that that's a homie he was like bros before hose
you know this guy literally went bros before hose buddy he
did not protect
I got three, though.
I ult this.
When I have...
When the Starlord shows up, I'll ult it.
And then I'll save my cards.
Where the fuck is our Starlord?
I've been saving this for so long.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my god.
It's fine.
Am I the only one shooting at her?
am i okay okay please okay there you go i felt like i was
like i'm just shooting playing cards at the bird in the sky
like that guy should not have been up there for so long i
had a feeling i was literally the only one shooting at the
hella no he did not the the name or did not switch targets
our magneto literally saved his uh He literally saved it for
me.
That's why he was like bros before hoes.
That's why I was like, I appreciate it, bro.
Thank you.
Oh, that sucks.
Yeah, God of Death versus...
Who would win?
A bunch of fucking plagues.
Jesus Christ, he got destroyed in the bird form.
That's what I'm saying.
That should have been what's happening to me.
That's really that's what I'm saying.
I was like, how come our hella died so fast Yet, yet I felt
like I'm shooting hella forever
Swear to God he fucking aimed it for me.
Did you see that he actually aimed it for me?
Oh My god, oh my god, okay.
It's okay.
It's okay Mine, mine, mine, mine, mine, mine Blow up, blow
up, blow up, blow up Blow up, blow up, blow up Okay We have
to kill these guys Oh my, okay That was on me, I didn't
realize how Fucking low I was there That was on me Oh my god
I was not paying, I was like Not paying to my HP
There you go, I should I swear to God, guys, we better be
looking at the goddamn hello.
Wait a minute.
I'm gonna keep my...
Why is the hell a still?
Disappear.
I have worse old.
I can't believe...
I don't have all for this.
Oh.
There we go.
Just throw more cards, bro.
Yeah, I blew up so fast.
That's why I was so surprised.
I was, like, not expecting myself to, like, die that quickly
in my ult.
I was like, what the fuck happened to me?
If I went aggressive, because I was like, I'll be fine,
right?
I was full HP.
Clearly, I was not fine.
Goodbye, Mac.
Oh.
There we go, at least I got him.
Look, our mag comes back, but the hell that does it.
So these are little things we can take.
Oh, he has diamond form.
I miscounted the cooldown.
I'll be down here.
Thank you.
I shall wait here.
Oh my god, that's goddamn stupid shield.
Yeah, votes, dude.
The hard part, at least I get DPS more here.
There we go.
I'm not gonna go aggression right now.
Yeah, you might notice.
You might, oh my god, that's unlucky.
That is so unlucky.
I have to reload, are you fucking...
Jesus Christ.
Hey, guys.
I'm still on the Emma
Okay, I can't do anything about it I'm just to, I'm just to
support Okay, here we go It's okay We just got a farm It's
okay, I'm here We are undefeatable I'm still on point.
It's okay.
I don't know how I live for so long.
It's not okay.
Oh my god.
We all went triple support.
We all got it.
Guys, you got a touch point.
You got a touch point.
The current score is 0, 2, 3.
Guys, in the end, it might not have been okay.
Might not have been okay guys.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Make way for the King of Tees.
I will have to say...
No.
Can I go Hella and you go you go Namur?
I will have to say I've never played Namur before.
That...
I will have to say that it wasn't me this time.
Okay?
It was me against Like I don't know what happened to
everyone else and we are on triple support.
So we have no damage It's like the only ones that were alive
were the supports and all we could do was just keep each
other alive and like against the fucking Emma And I'm like
I'm guys like I don't know.
I don't know.
She's like a fucking diamond form like what am I good?
I have playing cards versus a goddamn diamond.
What the fuck am I gonna do against that guy?
But my cards are made of paper, guys.
She's made of literal diamond.
I can't even give diamonds a paper cut.
Oh, wait, man.
They can put a Twitch prom.
They can think.
Yeah, let me just throw my cards really, really hard.
That should work.
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
Okay.
That was crazy.
I feel like I have to be like...
Jesus, Chris.
Ah, burns so fast.
I hope someone looks at our head up.
Oops, alright.
Look, you wanted heals from me.
Alright, that's what you're gonna get.
If you want Gambit heals, I will destroy.
I will destroy your fucking platforms.
Like, I can't control that, guys.
Unfortunately, my cards cannot...
It's not very precise.
It is a range.
Okay.
I want to use my anti, but...
Unfortunately, like...
My team is...
Even with triple support.
Oh, they double support all this!
They double support all this!
That's good, that's good, that's...
Okay, so, um...
I could not cleanse that because I ran out of cards.
I may or may not have ran out of cards there.
But it's okay.
I do have another one.
The word now, now.
They use all alts, guys.
We can only go up from here.
There we go.
See?
Oh my god, there.
See, you can't kneel.
She can't kneel anymore.
We cracked your legs.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
I refuse to Okay, we're fine.
I was like I refuse to let the well me he actually tried a
solo well me he's one He is actually one.
I thought I could get help You needed some help.
Oh my god, we killed him there we go Actually solo welled me
that fucking freak I had an emerald again, be careful.
I had a feeling he was going to as well.
I was like, I didn't have my dash.
All right.
Good luck, everyone.
There we go.
Yay!
We pushed through.
We did it.
All right, here we go.
A man of singular purpose.
Yeah.
It's just a solo of me.
Doesn't matter.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, I thought I would get that.
I can't remember if I didn't get that anti off.
There we go.
I got that anti off, though.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
I had a feeling he was behind us.
I'm backing out, guys.
Like, fuck that shit.
We're not... Oh, I bumped into a wall.
Oh, yeah.
I can't beat.
There we go.
It's okay.
I didn't die, though.
Might as well be a KDA player right now.
It's literally free alt charge for me.
I know that.
I know that name where it's somewhere.
That's all he does.
He's literally like, he finds a hiding spot and then fucking
goes at it.
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
There's nothing to panic about.
All right, here we go.
They're gonna have they're gonna All this but Do not worry
Boom Clear Okay Okay Alright it's okay See look at that Look
at that Look at It's okay It's okay you're alive You have
You have regen You have Re Oh my I swear to God Please
everyone shoot this one guy there you go see nothing to
worry about where the fuck is the name or where the fuck is
this name or like i'm where is he is he behind us he's
behind us isn't he i fucking knew it i knew he was behind us
all right we are so fucking scared for some reason are you
fucking jump and that's why the car didn't go through that's
crazy he actually jumped and because of that it actually
helped him the hardest part of triple support is that
please kill him please thank you oh my god is he behind yet
again okay he's dead okay he's dead Who would have thought
he was behind again?
Whenever I pop my ult, I'm gonna do it whenever they pop
Invisal and then block the projectile.
There you go.
I'm just like, is he behind?
Is he behind me, isn't he?
Shit, I got... I...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I almost messed up there.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, so I think...
Name or name.
He's gonna use it, isn't he?
Okay, we got this.
This all never-ending support.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
The never-ending support.
Please, please kill him.
Please kill him.
Oh!
It never falls.
Oh, okay.
That's okay.
I'll just save it for myself.
Everything is okay.
Who is complaining?
Oh, it's Seric Mantis.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with their fucking gambit?
He's doing his best.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking like 360 everywhere.
I'm trying to...
Oh my god, bro, I'm trying to make sure everybody is getting
healed, but not everybody is getting healed.
I guess we back out.
We're so scared.
It's not gonna come for me, right?
There we go.
That's free all charge right there.
I'll take these free all charge.
There you go.
He can't aim.
That's good.
Oh my god, our hellas was fucking crazy, bro.
Yeah, I'm fucking gotta come back.
to you.
Oh, I'm so confused.
Where are we going?
I swear.
I'm like, I'm like looking everywhere.
I'm like, where are we going?
I'm going to push the cart.
All right.
Oh, God.
There we go.
That's fine.
Gambit never falls here, too.
That's okay.
I think.
Oh, I I've never seen this area before.
Where am I?
Wait, that was a new area.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
There we go.
Two down.
I swear to God, if I see a Namor right behind me, I swear to
God.
Okay.
Oh, there's a I'm shooting him as hard as I can There's only
so much as hard as I can shoot
Oh my god They are solid forever I have to do a DPS with
this Please!
Captain America, please!
Oh my god Oh my god!
Oh my god.
I have to.
I'm gonna fucking, I'm gonna go for the supports.
The three supports in the corner.
I'm gonna go for the fucking.
Okay, I got the fucking gavit.
I got both supports.
One support I didn't get.
The one support I didn't get.
Please, I got so many plays.
Oh my
god.
Oh god, okay.
I like this.
I have 33 kills.
Okay.
I'll go guard the heals.
Like, I think I have to...
My goal is just to kill the supports.
My...
I literally killed, I kept killing their supports over and
over again.
Finally.
Oh my god, I literally got three.
Of course, the one support I didn't kill was Makinia, the
one that had their support all.
Oh my god, bro.
I'm gonna be...
Oh my god.
I don't...
I don't want...
I'm going in with, like, low expectations here for this
game.
I was just pushing against...
Pushing against this Elo right now.
30 seconds before you attack.
Yeah, it's my first rank match too.
Alright, I'm gonna go get the easy alt charge real quick.
I fucked it up, but that's fine.
He lives.
Oh my god, why are we backing up?
Guys, oh my god.
We're backing up.
You guys are all, guys, I don't know if our takes notice
this, but you are literally full HP.
I should not be, where is my mag?
Mag, mag, I, come here, come here, come here, come.
Mag, mag.
Holy shit!
Our mag, oh my god, our mag does not play mag.
Our mag actually does not play tank.
There is no way he is so scared right now.
That's actually crazy.
Look, we have a pick.
We actually have a pick.
Like, I'll keep the...
Oh my god.
my god the amount of free space we have we have given them i
don't understand my team
that's actually crazy we have given so much free space for
no reason i'm keeping this all just in case they tp oh my
god they our mag has just i was like front lightning oh like
i don't understand why our mag was so scared he was full hp
wait he's lord he's lord i don't understand really lord we
have three supports i am so scared he's like oh god I hit
one time, I can't go forward, guys.
I stubbed my toe.
He literally fucking gets hit one time and can't fucking
push up.
The fact that I was in front of him as a guy with 275 HP and
I was okay.
I, everything was fine.
Bro, you're so scared of getting fucking infected.
Get ready.
I don't know now, but they got such a free fucking push
because we didn't push out for some fucking reason.
He was so goddamn scared.
Bullets are scary.
Master of Magnetism.
That's so true.
He did not believe in us at all.
It's actually wild.
so fucking scared for no reason.
Oh, oh my god.
That's crazy that he's going forward now.
That's actually crazy.
Like, oh, now you're not scared.
Sick.
Bro,
I got, okay, we had to go over.
worry.
There you go.
Bullet no longer scary.
Wait, he is 1 HP.
Oh my god!
Mac!
Mac, you cannot be fucking with me right now.
Like, are you actually serious, Mac?
No, I'm trying.
I'm I'm actually trying to heal you so bad.
Okay, there you go.
Now he's got the power of friendship.
He's got...
He actually...
He's got the power of friendship.
Now he's okay.
No, he...
Spunky almost died there because he actually finally pushed
him.
that's insane that's actually insane he got drunk with power
he was just like guys no guys he's like oh wait i do have
triple support let me just be the only one to run up to them
and respond
oh yeah 20 points after like the fucking shit i had to pull
20 have the same final hits as our fucking date.
Jesus Christ.
Bro, look at their gambit.
Five final hits.
I have 13 final hits.
This man has five.
I literally had to, like, kill their support.
It's like, at least four.
times before we could fucking win.
Wait, was he Lord?
There's no way.
Oh my God, he was Lord.
Oh my God.
Oh, I'm sorry, bro.
Clearly I needed this more than you, bro.
Look at my team.
I needed it more.
I was more passionate.
Oh, did I do it?
Was it?
Oh my God.
Wait, did I do it correctly?
Wait, how do I even know if...
Okay, I have no...
Oh, completed!
Yay!
I'll play one more.
I feel a little weird if I just...
Don't worry, guys.
I'll do one more.
I think...
Maybe the next game will be more relaxing.
Maybe the next game.
Maybe...
Let me...
I can tone down the moderation now.
Yeah.
Oh, I never saved it.
Whoops.
Ooh, that's funny.
Okay, I don't think they noticed.
Because it was like, make sure to have it on moderation too.
But it said I completed it.
So I did it.
Because they're like, make sure to have it on moderation
level 2.
And I was like, moderation level 1.
Let's go.
All right.
Whatever happens in this game is the last game.
I'm sorry.
I know it was the shortest Marvel rival stream of your life.
But I do have...
I'm trying to be a responsible.
person.
I mean, it really just does, like, counteract to the whole
point that I almost forgot about the sponsor that I had to
do.
It might...
But I said I was trying to be a responsible person.
Like, I didn't say I'm doing a good job at it.
I made it, though.
Yeah, the thing is, I did make it in the end.
I got there.
we we got it yeah it worked out it worked out i did my
responsible job
exactly and now since i did my sponsored portion we can go
to times square and join my people i am i have the i get the
most inspiration when i'm like um when i'm closer to a
deadline no my
i see him my people it wasn't meant to be it really truly
wasn't all right it's low key time i got denied i worked so
hard for it too no cake for me unfortunate
no cake for me
oh we both bansu that's cool
yeah deadline midnight submit it 1140 not even close god
thank you for the videos thank you thank you exactly brings
me back to the good old days at university where you submit
a paper at 1140 uh 59
oh you'll need a top match team to win this one Mantis okay
we don't have a lot of heroes but we'll go with this
hey pizza
what was it there was like you know like like people who get
their their most creativity or like most motivation when
they're like when they're like when the deadline is just
there what's that word called for it i know there's a
specific word for it is it pressured when you're most
pressured i feel like there's a word for it because i get my
most creative ideas uh yes it's procrastinating but like i
literally get like my most creative ideas when i'm like uh
when the deadline is like getting when the deadline gets
closer it's not good obviously i would i would I will say
that's not, but I actually get the most creative.
Yeah, under pressure, yeah.
Spider, isn't that weird?
Yeah, I work best under, like, under pressure.
It's not good, though, but I don't know.
My brain is just fucked up like that.
I had, like, the most brilliant.
I, like, pivoted so hard for my...
For the...
What the fuck?
For the 900k.
And by pivot, I meant, like, today.
Like in terms of like how to do the, how to do the thing I
want to show you guys.
They have Loki at them.
Not going to be great.
He will stop.
I just died.
Keep driving.
Oh my god.
I fucked up the info.
It's fine.
He doesn't know.
It's okay.
He did not know.
Guys.
I do not have...
Oh my god, he's punching me.
No, it already automatically counted.
I don't have to end the stream before midnight.
Like, the moment it counted, it just goes like...
They're just like, okay, we're done.
Nope, okay.
I saw him, I saw him, but like...
You know, like, when the arrow just is fired, and then you
see him?
I literally saw the arrow got fired.
And then I was like, it's too late.
It's too late for me There's nothing to do It's like Mr.
President kid.
Oh my god.
Okay Okay, oh Coffee first Hawking free coffee Okay,
I I I had to do that because there is a Hawking right behind
and I have pinged them three times.
What?
I have pinged this guy three times and we didn't even look
behind us.
It's actually crazy.
That's not even on...
That's on them.
They did not look back.
There's a mag behind.
We're at it.
Got it.
That's on them at that point.
Like, there's nothing I can do to fix that.
Oh my god.
You fucking ran away from my thing.
I can't hear anything about it.
Hello.
I got one healer.
I only wish I had done it myself.
Hello guys, there is a venom behind us unfortunately.
And I shall now heal.
Hello, guys.
I am sorry, but I had to back up.
We gotta protect for her supports, guys.
I should have looked back at her, Luna.
I didn't think that...
I saw that he was okay with Venom, but I didn't realize the
Iron Fist came out as well.
I...
all right luna um you you're running away from my i will say
she did run i guess i'll stay here now i she she did she
look okay okay it's fine
All right, here we go.
I am a little scared of that though.
I waited.
I did indeed wait, waited, but I had to.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's the Hawkeye.
I.
Don't worry
Who will touch for us Who Who would be the toucher Because
it's definitely not me Hello?
Okay.
Thanks so much.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Okay, there is a...
Yeah, save.
What the fuck?
And here we go again.
Frozen, we're frozen, guys.
It's killing.
What the fuck?
You get a weapon.
Oh, your friend's not doing so well.
Your friend might have just got fucking shit on by the
Hawkeye.
Oh, so did our other DPS.
Don't worry.
Don't.
Okay.
Does their mag have ult or no?
I think you're just saving it for me.
Oh my god, he never missed, yes.
He never missed me.
I'm sorry, buddy.
Where is he?
Where's our Luna?
Oh my god, try to copy my Luna.
She died.
She got headshot.
Okay, please touch.
I'm skating as fast as I can.
Where's the hawk guy?
I'm about to skate.
It's okay.
He can't get me.
He can't.
He got me in the end.
Bro, he had to jump.
He actually had to jump.
Look, dude.
Bro, he was trying so hard.
hard oh if I did get here it'd be fucking cool yeah you saw
us I knew he was gonna fucking try and get me that's
unfortunate you know what you know what I'm I'm going
Raccoon.
I have a smaller hitbox.
I have...
It's a smaller hitbox for the fucking Hawkeye.
He's gotta find my head.
Yeah, try and hit this.
That's right.
Where am I, Hawkeye?
Try and hit this.
Yeah, Adam is trying to flank a lot, so we just call him
out.
He's trying to do something about him.
Is Red bigger on Rocket?
No, it's bigger on Jeff's, though.
Jeff's entire hitbox is literally his fucking body.
Yeah, there's no way.
He can't get me now.
It's not looking so good when our Luna's MVP.
You know it's not looking so good when especially the Luna
is MVP.
rangers thank you for the twitch bravling thank you yeah
yeah it's all right it may or may not be our luna no look
you can't headshot me when i don't have a head to headshot
that's right i don't have to look at anyone no more i i
should be careful here there you go there you go he can kill
him right I don't know.
I don't do anything on the roof, I think.
Yeah, care.
All right.
Oh, he doesn't have res anymore, right?
Don't worry, I got you.
Wait, where did he go?
There you go.
I was like, you know, I got you.
See, I told you.
I'm so safe now from Hawkeye.
Left side still.
Can't do anything now.
Look at that.
I'm going to get rid of my gang here.
and then hope to get me now i'm right here that's right the
phrase is on the sky it's okay look at that i just run sky
res oh and they're not they're not doing portal what the
see that it's that easy
Oh, Ranger, you should have been here like the last game.
I earned that victory last game.
Oh my god, they're really...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they have no healers.
Guys, they have no healers.
Let's go.
Their Adam's not healing.
Their Adam's not a healer.
I know that.
okay wait wait what the fuck oh my god
you know what fuck it let's do this let's wait let's fuck it
let's go let's go oh my god on our right side no they they
had a dc their actual healer dc'd what happens guys they're
like because their atom is a flanker their atom doesn't
actually heal so they're actual the only healer oh wait it's
not even a healer oh wait who is it oh their tank it's their
tank jk i was spreading misinformation misinformation as
always but like they lost their they lost their main tank
they lost their main tank moving them down Oh my god!
I deserve this.
I fucking deserve this.
Look at that.
I told you this was the fucking big brain play?
Can't headshot me when I have no head!
This is it.
What rank?
Surprisingly celestial, I know.
But I think all the really good players now are in eternity.
But...
I have not played ring like as consistently as I should
That's right You gotta do shit watch this Oh he wants to He
wants oh my god He wants to headshot me That's right How can
you headshot me now?
Oh my god I could That's right Where's the head now That's
fucking right I got res too!
Look at this!
There we go!
It's fucking easy!
No head!
Watch this!
Let's go!
Yeah, I can't headshot me here too!
That's why I'm behind the corner!
Oh no, wait, can you never miss?
Wait!
Oh no, guys, he never missed!
okay but I'm standing here oh shit okay that that was on me
I thought I saw him walk past me and I was like he's gonna
find me he's gonna find me okay that might have been a
little too opportunistic right there guys they they are
missed they are missing one but they still have the rest of
their team with the are you kidding me how what touched me
my toe did he touch my toe wait i got it what it was
actually my toe it was actually my toe
This guy actually fucking touched my toe
I was like wondering like what the fuck what happened like
my fucking toe was was caught There you go Oh yeah, I have
red yeah,
no if they had their full team we would it would we would
have lost we did not deserve that win ball team it he like
grabbed my toe and like fucking slammed slammed dumped me
into the fucking pit we don't deserve that well and then
this guy comes back
dc and loki bro the guy that dc was not the loki it was
literally your fucking main tank
It's not weak guys.
We haven't won yet.
They still have We haven't won yet guys.
It's bro the fact that they made it so close They fucking
still took out so much time from us in a 5v6 setting
It's not ideal.
It's it's definitely not ideal
It's not, not, not victory yet, guys.
Maybe, maybe they'll leave.
You know, maybe they'll surrender.
I don't even trust myself to hide in there.
I'm just gonna...
Oh my god, that was actually an accident.
Whoops.
Lost my jetpack already.
Okay.
All right, don't let him see the res.
Oh my god, he saw the res.
I said don't let him see the res, and he saw the res, guys.
Don't die, please.
Don't die, because we...
That is very unfortunate that...
Get him, get him.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
that's why I saw the Adam I was like I'm running I he can't
climb upstairs I know I know I can survive the stairs I was
like oh my god he can he only has legs shitty human legs so
much for being a perfect human being he can't jump this win
is for you dokey bird more like this dc is for me this dc is
for dokey bird wait he can not here he got his fucking ankle
slashed yeah he's going through physical therapy right now
to be proud of but we take those he adam's currently going
through physical therapy and Marble Rivals.
That's why he can't fly right now.
Agreement confirmed.
Thank you, Doki.
I will disconnect from the enemy tag team now.
You want it?
There you go.
Yeah, Loki was your fan.
The battle starts in five.
For legal reasons, I did not rig the match, guys.
For legal reasons, I did not fix the match.
There is no win trading going on.
Like, I don't know.
This guy just has shitty...
Guys, I swear to...
Legally, there is no win trading going on, guys.
He just happened to DC while I was in the same game.
Oh, my God.
He's back.
He's one.
So, Adam and her spawn.
Still there, dude.
I'm gonna go.
Is he still trying to kill us?
A frozen.
okay okay that's fine uh-huh wink wink yeah no match fixing
yeah win the wink
just a crazy coincidence that the happen the enemy team
someone he's seen on the enemy team and that they also
happen to have an Adam that was just flanking the entire
time.
The Adam is Adam mission.
Oh, yeah, I'm like one game away from ranking up.
Guys, we are not doing one more.
I do not.
These games were like actual Elo terrorism there.
I just happened.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Can I get...
I'm going to take my chance.
no no why did you be small no no i'm too big i'm too big no
oh my god look how small they are i felt the gotcha look how
small they are right here oh my god wait wait no there's
still there's still purpose and what I do.
There's still purpose.
Right here, little ones.
I shall now put on a show.
A little victory dance for my two wins.
That's right.
Right here.
A little.
There we go, guys.
A little victory dance, everyone.
Yeah.
You're enjoying it, right?
Yeah, Hulk.
That's right!
The dance of my people!
Let's go!
This is the way.
Wait, what if I'm gonna re-queue?
I must find my people.
I must find...
my people.
Oh my!
Okay.
Let's go.
You so, I got, oh my god, bro, we're all just chilling.
Oh my god, and he's grilling.
Oh, hey, hey, hi, man.
Oh, man, they're Wolverine just grilling right now.
He's just grilling.
All right, guys.
I'm going to call it here.
Like I said, it was going to be a short rival stream today.
I have to do more.
more behind the scenes work for tomorrow as well as the new
year's countdown next week as well there's a lot of big
projects going on after it's just a lot going on i i really
can't say what it is but uh that was a fun stream it was a
fun stream i made made it to the deadline and that's all we
wanted so we had fun watching me today uh we got we have a
100 win rate today too which is always a plus um you never
know what's gonna happen in these games it felt like
everything was happening the last those last two games um
but if you're new here and want to check me out more uh my
name is donkurt i usually stream on uh youtube so please
follow me over on youtube for my main platform you want to
know when i stream on twitch feel free to follow me on
twitter because i usually tweet out whenever i'm on stream
um and when i'm on twitch when i'm streaming on Twitch.
Anyone supporting me feel out of me's feel free to check out
my merch.
Exclamation point merch, socials, Twitter or YouTube.
That should lead me to everything.
Hey guys.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, pause to check.
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you still friend me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
I'll figure out someone in the raid.
I'll just go through my list.
But yeah, I'll raid someone.
If you want to stick around before the raid.
Bye everyone.
Bye!